A Charlie Brown Christmas has become a bonafide
holiday staple.
If you’re an adult who’s watched the show
multiple times, there are several details
you may have noticed about this seasonal classic
that younger viewers likely miss.
Let's investigate.
Just as Pig-Pen is perpetually surrounded
by dust clouds and Schroeder is almost always
next to his piano, Linus is hardly ever seen
without his trusty blue blanket.
He's got it with him outside in the snow,
and inside during rehearsals for the Christmas
play.
"Linus, you've got to get rid of that stupid
blanket!"
He's quite clearly attached to the thing.
Perhaps a little too attached.
"You think you're so smart with that blanket.
What are going to do with it when you grow
up?"
"Maybe I'll make it into a sportcoat."
You can't blame Linus for not wanting to let
the blanket go: It appears to be made of 100%
pure magic.
It gets dragged through the snow all day without
getting soggy, and even serves as a remarkably
accurate slingshot.
Wait, did he just ice-skate with his security
blanket in his hand?
And now this is happening.
Later on, Lucy tries to get him to put down
the blanket so that he can dress up like a
shepherd for the Christmas play.
That's when Linus reveals that the blanket
can shapeshift, forming a perfect headdress
complete with a band in the middle.
Who manufactures this Swiss Army Security
Blanket?
We simply must have one.
A good chunk of A Charlie Brown Christmas
takes place at the local auditorium, where
the Peanuts gang is getting ready to put on
a Christmas play.
Charlie Brown is roped into the production
after he tells Lucy about his holiday depression,
and she feels the play will help him get into
the holiday spirit.
"Me?
You want me to be the director of the Christmas
play?"
"Sure, Charlie Brown.
We need a director.
You need involvement."
Charlie Brown eagerly leaps into his role
as director, but he can't seem to get anyone
to listen to him.
Perhaps more importantly, no one seems entirely
clear on what play they're even putting on.
At one point, Lucy hands out scripts to various
kids for roles like "innkeeper" and "shepherd."
Obviously, this suggests a Nativity play ... but
then she also asks Snoopy:
"Can you be a sheep?
How 'bout a cow?
How 'bout a penguin?"
Quite the menagerie, all told.
To complicated matters further, Schroeder
keeps trying to score the play with upbeat
jazz, and at one point, Lucy suggests herself
for a plum-sounding role:
"What about the Christmas queen?
Hmm?"
So, is this some sort of highly conceptual,
staunchly avant-garde Nativity play?
Is it a variety show?
Does anyone really know?
To our ears, it all sounds a tad bit unfocused.
A Charlie Brown Christmas begins by focusing
on the titular character's own lack of satisfaction
with the holiday.
He tells Linus, in no uncertain terms:
"Christmas is coming, but I'm not happy.
I don't feel the way I'm supposed to feel."
He also repeatedly complains that the holiday
has grown too commercial.
His Scrooginess reaches dizzying new heights
when he sees Snoopy putting up a bunch of
decorations on his doghouse.
That's when he realizes the beagle is decking
the halls for a Christmas light contest that's
promising a cash prize.
"Oh no, my own dog gone commercial...
I can't stand it."
By the end of the special, we learn that Snoopy
not only entered the contest, but managed
to win first place.
We admit that Snoopy's decorated doghouse
looks very charming… but we have a few concerns.
He puts lights up all around the roof, hangs
a theoretically festive chain or two, and
even tops it all off with a star.
There's nothing wrong with his decorations
per se, but it ultimately amounts to little
more than a strand of lights and a couple
of baubles hanging around a doghouse.
How did this doghouse win out over all those
suburban properties?
Come to think of it, Charlie Brown's neighbors
don't appear to have put in much of an effort.
Where's everyone's Christmas lights?
Apart from the ultra-commercial Christmas
tree lot, it looks like people just weren't
feeling it that year.
Maybe Charlie Brown had every reason to be
depressed.
When the Christmas play rehearsals don't seem
to be working, Charlie Brown makes a passionate
plea:
"Look, Charlie Brown — what do you want?"
"The proper mood.
We need a Christmas tree!"
Lucy agrees and advises Charlie Brown to get
a great big aluminum Christmas tree.
Charlie Brown and Linus subsequently head
to the tree lot, where they ultimately decide
to take the scrawny real tree that remains
one of the most famous parts of the show.
The whole point of the scene is that Charlie
Brown picks this little twig of a tree, which
mirrors his own feelings about the season
… but when you look around at the rest of
the lot, you may have some questions.
It's arranged like a traditional Christmas
tree lot, but it soon becomes clear that the
tiny tree is the only real tree there.
The rest are made of aluminum.
"This really brings Christmas close to a person."
"Fantastic."
Setting aside the lack of real trees for a
moment, let's ask the obvious question: Who's
selling aluminum Christmas trees outside where
it's clearly been snowing?
Snow is wet, and the trees are made of delicate
metal.
Surely that would have messed up the merchandise,
no?
When Charlie Brown brings the tiny tree back
from the lot and presents it to his friends,
they call him names and full-on laugh at him.
Then Linus makes a stirring speech, passionately
quoting scripture in the hopes of emphasizing
the true meaning of Christmas.
That's when Charlie Brown decides to take
the tree home.
He thinks he can convince everyone that they
were wrong to make fun of the tree so long
as he can get the decorations right.
Charlie Brown gives up after the tree nearly
breaks in half from the weight of just one
ornament, but then the other kids come along
to help.
Linus wraps his blanket around the base, and
the kids use all the decorations from Snoopy's
doghouse to fill out the rest of the tree.
By the time the kids are done decorating with
all the lights and baubles, the tree looks
like it's grown about a dozen extra branches
and a whole bunch of extra needles.
In fact, it looks like a completely different
tree.
Is it a Christmastime miracle?
"What's going on here?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
TV shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.